oh hi welcome to game life you know what
Chris Baker I think we've been agreeing
on things a little bit too much lately
don't you working about no it's exactly
I think that we should have a fight I
think that we should have a a good
old-fashioned fight we should talk about
some controversial video games that we
disagree on what do you think I think
that's a terrible idea great you don't
know what you're talking all right Baker
first game we're going to talk about
Mirror's Edge sign xbox 360 playstation
3 it's a first-person hardcore game you
reviewed it for us so you know you know
well you're running and you're jumping
and it's just great like exhilarating
feeling of like jumping across buildings
and grabbing onto pipes and doing all
these sites you know crazy stupid things
trying to outrun the law I really
actually like Mirror's Edge got a little
bit repetitive for me but I love you
know how the game actually works but you
had some issues with it right yeah just
the fundamental experience of running
around doing doing first person parkour
is totally fun but there's a lot of
combat breaking that up there there are
a lot of guys who have guns pointed at
you you don't have a gun and it doesn't
really have a very good system to to
fight back at them and you die a lot and
there are some fantastic levels just out
in the open air where you're jumping
from rooftop to rooftop those those are
incredibly exhilarating but there are
also a lot of levels where you're just
in these cramped close quarters not
quite sure how to get to the next place
and just you know you know circling
around and circling around looking for
looking for a way out looking for a way
to advance so the developer dice has
created this whole new genre of games we
miss what this really striking aesthetic
but you know i'd be happy to play
another game in this genre but but the
way the levels are laid out the way that
the challenges in combat works it's very
frustrating I died over and over and
all right over again see here's the
thing there's there's frustrating games
but then those games that are way too
easy and I mean mirrors edge yes you do
die over and over and over again but
it's it's one of those things where like
you know every time you die it kind of
pulls you back a little bit and so it
makes you master that little stretch of
level that you're doing yeah there's
some trial and error going on when you
finally do it when you finally like pull
off this great big string moves outside
not one of those confine levels but
outside you really feel great about
yourself but you actually mastered
something like you very specifically I
mean the reason why you die and die and
die is because you're not nailing the
move precisely right and if you as soon
as you get that when you when you start
getting that feeling that's when
Mirror's Edge really shines that yeah
sometimes it is just a matter of really
honing your technique sometimes I think
it's a matter of the way the levels are
laid out the way the way it's not clear
where you're supposed to go next and
what you're supposed to do so this is
this is a really divisive game some
people just absolutely love it some
people think the frustrations really
outweigh the positives I mean for me
I'll take a little bit of frustration
I'll take a couple of like elements in a
game where I you know I'm kind of ticked
off at the game because it at least
engages my emotions like I mean you know
a lot of games that I've sworn at you
know or said like really really mean
things to how to be playing them like
those are the games that have engaged me
the most I mean yeah some games are just
BS but in yours edges case I think it
has enough pay off to kind of reward the
player for like getting a little bit
frustrated sometimes I am going to agree
with you though on the combat it really
just didn't need to be there I felt like
they've got like this like they had a
good like four or five our portal life
game with their good mechanics but they
just kind of had that stretch out and
make more difficult for the player and
they added combat and it didn't really
work one of the selling points was you
were supposedly you know you could get
through this game without killing any of
these people shooting at you could just
disarm them or clobber them and keep on
running Yeah right and about halfway
through about half way through i wanted
them all to die i wanted to be able to
shoot at the developers of this game for
me through so much torment so I yeah I
stopped trying to get through without
killing people yeah I I did everyone
eyes I just started killing every single
one of them there's like a big
achievement right i think if you don't
kill anybody think is 100.2 cheap but or
something like that it's I'll never know
it's something ya know and and honestly
I'm never going to finish the game quite
frankly because it got to the point
where we just getting a little
repetitive the ending is so so hard um I
can't wait to play the expansion pack I
can't wait to play the sequel but yeah
there are some real problems with this
game hmm so Prince of Persia is this
venerable old franchise it has you
clambering around inside you know
Sultan's palaces and underground tunnels
and these bikes lots of lots of spikes
and requires lots of acrobatic maneuvers
and and the games were famous for having
a mechanic that let you literally rewind
what was happening in the game just like
you would on a remote control on a DVD
if you died you just back up a few
seconds so before you died and you tried
again which a lot of people said would
have been really good for mirror's edge
yeah well you know now this new game
took a different tack they it's
impossible to die in this game but what
you have is uh is a magical partner who
pulls your fat out of the fire every
time you're about to die so let me just
say you know for the record before i get
into criticizing prince of persia um I
don't necessarily think that it's a bad
thing per se to have a game where you
cannot die I just sort of want to get
that on the table that in prince of
persia you cannot die if as soon as you
fall off a cliff you are immediately
brought back to that cliff like you're
never more than like two or three
seconds away from from where you died
with zero penalty whatsoever there's no
penalty now again braid hair braid
there's a game where you couldn't die
but it was about the puzzles you know
prince of persia to me felt like i had a
game genie turned on it felt like I was
cheating like that's what playing this
game felt like to me I think you know
just the core gameplay you know
clambering up
pets and then sliding down using your
gauntlet to slow your descent it's just
incredibly fun and you know i was still
i was still a little put out when i died
even even though i did sort of get
revived immediately it was you know I
you I was disappointed in myself I
didn't so much- I disappointed in you
too because I think you're on crack with
this this gameplay is fun thing and all
you're doing in prince of persia yeah
you're running on the columns and
jumping on the parapets and stuff like
that but it's all canned it's all done
for you like I mean you know Mirror's
Edge you've really got to make sure to
nail every single jump but in prince of
persia you just go up you hit the jump
button and you hit the other buttons and
it just does everything for you all you
do is you just enter in a little string
of button combination it's like playing
dragon's lair and once I realized that
it wasn't fun anymore cuz I realized I
wasn't doing anything the game was just
playing itself for me and I was just
sort of like helping it along I guess it
is fairly forgiving there's there's a
very large window you know maybe a half
second in which you can push a button
and get to the next point but you know
you're not you're not just jumping
across you are chaining together move
after move after move after move and I
think the sequences of chains are longer
than in previous games and frankly you
can get to the end of one of those and
die and i think it does back you up a
good 20 or 30 seconds I mean you know
yeah was in greenlawn some cases there's
a long kind of chain of stuff and it
backs you up all the way to the
beginning of it but they're really not
that long and the other thing is the
difficulty of this game does not scale
like every level is only as difficult as
the previous level and I mean the the
the challenges just don't ramp up and
difficulty at all so I mean once you get
it once you know what buttons to press
and when cuz all the timing is always
just the same like every time we run on
a wall you've run on a wall for the
exact same amount of time and once you
understand that takes like two or three
levels before you get it the the next 20
levels of the game are just the same
thing over and over again love the
graphics love the music like the story
like the characters you know all that
stuff is just top-notch the technology
we in the whole world right just all
interconnected it's it's great but I
feel like they really
sit with the gameplay i went back and i
played the old sands of time the first
time rewind game and it's in it's still
a lot of fun he just got more direct
control the games not just sort of you
know dragging you by the nose you're
high I like all the games in this
franchise but I think all three of the
previous ones had certain points where
where it just became really difficult
and frustrating I mean maybe they aired
too much in the sight of you know
hand-holding making it easy for you and
I have to say I'm not maybe halfway
through at this point so so maybe it
will get kind of grinding and repetitive
but but but so far it feels like prince
of persia with you know some of the so
the annoyances sand it off maybe maybe
I'll you know you'll will kick me in the
head and I'll come around to your way of
thinking again I've got to say after
mirrors edge and then prince of persia
i'm starting to come around to like
annoying games like I feel like you've
got to have some frustration you've got
to have some annoyance in the game if
you're going to have like hi so if
you're going to have joy like there's
Prince of Persia gets rid of all the
lows there are no lows it's an easy game
this blast right through that's never
frustrating ever but it also for me just
had no highs it was just a sort of flat
experience all the way through and if
Mirror's Edge you know it's sort of like
this when I was really frustrated than
really happy I'd rather have this if I'm
playing a game with you that's
frustration and annoyance enough for me
I I don't mind if it's a little more
easy thanks bigger